Blake Sheldon Gwen Stefani are making it
clear they want nobody but each other in
their brand-new music video for the duet
nobody but you
[Music]
[Applause]
ahead of their highly anticipated
Grammys performance of the track this
weekend the couple give fans a glimpse
into their personal life with visuals of
them enjoying a casual date at a diner
cuddling up on the couch with their dog
betty going for a late-night drive and
it even looks like the two are building
a house together
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now the couple splits their time between
Los Angeles and Blake's ranch in
Oklahoma so the video perfectly contrast
Blake's down-home roots with Gwen's more
glamorous side some of the footage even
appears to be a self shot home video
featuring a makeup free grin while Blake
showers her with kisses and while
speaking about the romantic ballad Blake
revealed I was about to go in and record
when I decided that it needed went on it
because it is our song
I think it's magic the love song is
featured on Blake's latest album
fully-loaded gods country along with 11
other tracks including hell right this
rarity duet with Trace Adkins and this
grammy-nominated hit gods country nobody
but you marks the third time they've
recorded the song together now in case
you forgot they released go ahead and
break my heart in 2016
their catchy holiday team you make it
feel like Christmas in 2017 so what do
you think of their new music video I
excited to see them take the stage at
the Grammys this weekend let us know in
the comments below
[Music]
hey I'm Graham O'Neill for more on your
favorite country stars click subscribe
or watch the videos over there